From an MCU adventure to a live-action adaptation
of a children's cartoon, these movies avoided R
ratings by ditching scenes that were overly
gory, too explicit, or simply in poor taste.
There are only a few big DC heroes that you
can easily imagine in an R-rated feature,
but Batman is definitely among them. He's a
gritty character who operates in a dreary city
fighting underworld criminals, but all his movies
— even the Christopher Nolan ones — have always
been PG-13 or tamer. When director Zack Snyder
paired the Dark Knight with the Man of Steel
in "Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice,"
though, he wanted to go darker than ever
before. If Snyder had gotten his way, "Batman
v Superman" would have been even more mature.
"Tell me… do you bleed?"
Snyder has spoken before about extended
versions of certain scenes in the movie
that would have earned it an R rating.
He revealed to Collider that there were
some violent moments that had to be trimmed,
like the opening. The director clarified —
"The opening of the movie, the North
African sequence, is really much different."
These deleted moments weren't seen in theaters
— but they did show up in the Ultimate Cut of
the film, which was released on Blu-ray and DVD.
Speaking to Entertainment Weekly, star Ben Affleck
said he was completely in favor of the more
violent version being made available, saying —
"Why not have an R-rated version that you
release for download or on DVD
later? I think that's smart."
Set during a wild post-graduation party,
"Can't Hardly Wait" follows a group of teens
as they look for love, sex, and revenge. With
some edgy late-'90s gags and a PG-13 rating,
it's not quite a sex comedy — but it's also
not exactly family friendly. Either way,
it was almost rated R, and there was plenty left
on the cutting room floor after the studio made
the last minute decision to help it get a wider
audience. Actor Seth Green told Vulture in 2015 —
"There was like 40 minutes of that
movie that was cut out. The movie
was originally an R-rated movie.
Sony, in the midst of putting it
out — it was at the very beginning of
the reemergence of the teen comedy — was
scared. [...] Everyone was really kind of
concerned about what it was going to be."
According to the actor, CGI was used
to delete a beer bong in one scene,
while a sequence involving weed
brownies had to be removed.
Some deleted scenes may even help explain other
odd moments in the PG-13 version
of the movie. Green continued —
"[Jason] Segel's got a watermelon that he's
filled with vodka and kept in his freezer for
all of senior year, and then he brings
it out to celebrate. Everybody goes for
it, and it shatters on the ground. So that's why
he's eating watermelon for the rest of the movie."
It's one thing when an R-rated sex comedy is
cut down to get a softer rating like "Can't
Hardly Wait." It's much more rare, though,
for a film that's designed to be a family
comedy — one based on an iconic children's
cartoon, no less — to contain R-rated moments
that had to be pulled. If writer James Gunn and
actor Sarah Michelle Gellar are to be believed,
though, that's exactly what happened with the
2002 live-action adaptation of "Scooby-Doo."
According to Gunn, the movie was originally
slapped with an R rating by the MPAA,
and plenty of changes had to be made.
One scene that was deleted depicted a
soul-swapped Daphne and Velma locking lips. As
Gellar confirmed on "Watch What Happens Live" —
"There was an actual kiss between
Daphne and Velma that got cut. I
feel like the world wants to see
it. I don't know where it is."
That's not all — as Gellar tells it,
there was also a scene removed that
raised questions over Fred's
sexuality. She elaborated —
"There's always been an implication about Fred
being interested in both parties. It all got cut."
"He planned this somehow, didn't he?"
"Hey, good lookin'!"
When Jim Carrey came to fame in the mid-'90s,
it was for a string of vulgar comedies that
included "The Mask" and "Ace Ventura: Pet
Detective." Though they were all rated PG-13,
they pushed the envelope as far as they could with
jokes that stretched the boundaries of good taste.
For the 1994 Farrelly brothers classic "Dumb
and Dumber," one scene was filmed that pushed
the movie's inappropriateness levels
way over the edge. Watching it back now,
it's pretty easy to understand
why it was made much shorter.
The moment comes at a truck stop, when Harry and
Lloyd stop to refuel their vehicle and stretch
their legs. Lloyd goes to use the men's room and
spots a little bit of graffiti scrawled on the
stall that promises some "manly love" at 2:15
AM. Noticing it's exactly 2:15 at that moment,
Lloyd turns around to find Sea Bass entering
the men's room. The scene made it into the
movie's final cut — but what didn't are
some of the violent statements that the
trucker makes towards Lloyd. The rest of
the film may have been full of gross-out
gags and over-the-top vulgarity, but
this explicit threat of sexual assault
and murder would have no doubt pushed
the picture into R-rated territory.
Steven Spielberg's "Jaws" might not be classified
as a horror movie by today's standards, but it
definitely had some spine-tingling scares that
had audiences in 1975 jumping out of their seats.
Despite being centered around a bloodthirsty
shark that's menacing a coastal community,
it might surprise younger film fans who
haven't yet seen it that the film is
actually rated PG and contains very little actual
bloodshed. Most of the deaths are off-screen,
and the shark itself isn't even seen clearly very
often. In many ways, it's that lack of gore that
contributes to the film's scare factor — but
if the movie had been released as originally
intended, it would have included at least one
graphic moment likely warranting an R rating.
In the movie, Chief Brody's son Michael and
his friends are out sailing when their boat
is overturned by the shark. Coming to their
aid is a man in a paddleboat — but in what
would have been the most jaw-dropping
moment in the movie, the shark emerges
out of nowhere and devours the man, dragging
him under as he clings to a screaming child.
In a behind-the-scenes featurette, actor Ted
Grossman, who played the victim, admitted —
"It was just so violent, so
horrendous, that they couldn't use it."
Spielberg agreed, saying that it was "too
bloody" and that the scene was "in bad taste."
"I'm not gonna waste my time arguing with a man
who's lining up to be a hot lunch.
I'm gonna see you later, Brody."
"Indiana Jones and the Temple of Doom" is famously
one of the films that prompted the creation of the
PG-13 rating, as some parents were outraged
at some of the violence in the PG-rated flick
during test screenings. The action-packed prequel
sees the whip-wielding relic hunter in India,
facing off against a demonic cult that engages in
human sacrifice. The most infamous scene involves
the cult's leader tearing the still-beating
heart out of a man's chest and holding it aloft.
The final cut is pretty violent, but it was
almost even worse — a number of scenes were
removed from the film, presumably so it
could avoid an R rating. One depicted
a Thuggee torturer who's seen brutalizing a
group of slave children before he himself is
burned by lava in grisly fashion. Reporting
on the uproar surrounding the film, The New
York Times revealed that censors in the United
Kingdom were horrified that "Indiana Jones and
the Temple of Doom" had managed to get a PG rating
in the States. Journalist Aljean Harmetz wrote —
"James Ferman, secretary of the British board,
said that 'Indiana Jones,' as it stands,
could not even receive the
more restrictive 15 rating,
which prohibits children under age 15 from
seeing the film. To get a 15 rating, he said,
a scene depicting 'the slow burning to death of
a man who is in absolute agony' must be trimmed."
In 2022, "Black Adam" was supposed to
change the hierarchy of power in the DC
Extended Universe with the arrival of Dwayne
Johnson as the titular anti-hero. Instead,
the movie bombed at the box office, and James
Gunn and Peter Safran's DC reboot was announced
soon after. Unlike Gunn's R-rated redo of
"The Suicide Squad" from the year prior,
though, "Black Adam" had some scenes removed
and altered to tone down the blood and gore.
"Heroes don't kill people."
"Well, I do."
According to producer Hiram Garcia,
"Black Adam" was originally rated R,
and some scenes had to be axed in order to get the
PG-13 rating the studio wanted. He told Collider —
"We really wanted to make sure that
we honored the character of Black
Adam. One of the things he's known
for is his aggression and violence,
and to do a Black Adam movie that didn't have
that just wouldn't have been authentic. So
we always went into this knowing that we
were going to push it as far as we did."
The only deleted scene that has come to
light so far was discussed by VFX artists
Nikos Kalaitzidis and Greg Teegarden in
an interview with Befores & Afters. They
described a moment where Black Adam violently
tears an arm from a mercenary soldier,
and it spasms after hitting
the ground. Teegarden joked —
"You can't have a disembodied hand laying on the
ground and the finger just
all of a sudden twitching."
It's rare that the "Star Trek" franchise
goes too far with its content — but in
the series' second big screen outing, the
creators almost went overboard with one
particular scene. The film that remains the
most beloved in the franchise, "Star Trek II:
The Wrath of Khan," saw Ricardo Montalbán's
genetically augmented super tyrant return
from exile and seek revenge on Captain Kirk.
There was an entire character removed from a
key subplot that involved Khan's quest for
vengeance, though — the villain's child.
The toddler was originally supposed to pop up
at the climax of the film, when Khan detonates
the Genesis Device in a last ditch effort to kill
Kirk. In a deleted scene, the device sucks the kid
into its vortex before destroying the entire ship.
The full scene has never surfaced, but images
from the sequence were published in StarBlazer
magazine in 1982. With the horrific death of
an infant at the center of this major scene, it's
not hard to see why the whole thing was scrapped.
When one conjures up an image
of an R-rated Marvel movie,
"Thor" probably isn't the hero that springs to
mind. However, according to actor Christian Bale,
who played the villainous Gorr the God Butcher
in "Thor: Love and Thunder," there are actually
a series of deleted scenes that would have
made the Thunder God's fourth solo outing
an R-rated affair. Regarding his collaboration
with director Taika Waititi, Bale told Inverse —
"With 'Thor: Love and Thunder,' Taika and
me, we kind of knew that some of the stuff
we were doing probably wouldn't end up in the
film, but we wanted to just push it and see."
So what happened? Despite their wish to push the
boundaries of what could appear in an MCU movie,
both Bale and Waititi eventually agreed that the
scenes they shot weren't right. Bale continued —
"Ultimately, it is and should be a film that all
the family can go and enjoy. And Chris Hemsworth,
a couple of times he looked at me it
was like, 'Dude, that's a little too
far. I don't think anyone's gonna want to
see that unless it's an R-rated film.'"
"We really need to stop meeting like this."
"Call the ax."
"I'll call the ax when you call the dentist."
Despite those moments not making it to theaters,
Bale says he has no regrets since he
had a great time filming regardless.
Based on a series of young adult novels,
the "Divergent" films follow Tris Prior,
a defiant young woman in a dark future where
people are segregated based on their virtues.
When she joins the Dauntless faction due to her
bravery, she realizes that she is different from
the rest — and she must keep her unique nature
a secret as the world teeters on the brink
of war. Squarely aimed at tweens and teens,
the first movie in the franchise had to cut
some moments that were deemed too harsh for
the PG-13 rating the studio was aiming for.
Despite being directly adapted from a sequence
in the book, it was decided that the scene in
"Divergent" in which Dauntless rookie Edward is
stabbed in the eye was simply too brutal to show.
Though it did find its way onto the deleted
scenes portion of the home video release,
its removal from the actual film clearly
disappointed actor Ben Lamb, who considered
his character's brutal disfigurement a highlight
of the production. Lamb told Collider —
"The scene that I really enjoyed the most
was the eye stabbing. It's very gruesome."
According to director Neil Burger, the
eye stabbing scene was actually removed
to fix the flow of the movie rather
than to help it get a PG-13 rating.